welcome to another doctor Sadler's
honest review this time I'm going to be
looking at the book more than happiness
Buddhist and stoic wisdom for a
skeptical age by Antonia mcaro who I'll
tell you about in just a minute so this
is a series that this book fits solidly
into because what I'm doing is reviewing
recent books primarily in practical
philosophy so philosophy and that has to
do with our lives our relationships or
jobs so you can expect there's also a
good bit of overlap with self-help and
personal development and leadership
studies as well now I'm Tonio mcaro is
somebody who have actually met at the
stoic calm that was held in London I
believe in 2018 where both of us were
presenters and she has been part of the
philosophical counseling movement in
England and Europe for quite some time
really since its beginnings there she is
a psychotherapist and also somebody who
has done quite a lot of research into
these fields so it turns out it's really
quite an excellent book she she gave me
a copy a while back when I began doing
these reviews and I'm just finally
getting to it now
so we always start off with a little bit
about the style the structure and some
summary of the work and let me say that
this is actually a fairly short but but
you know I won't say dense in the bad
sense of being impenetrable or anything
like that but there's a lot packed in
does so there's a hundred and seventy
eight pages of total text and then quite
a few endnotes and book recommendations
and references and and a really great
index as well and it's organized as you
can expect into chapters and I'll just
run through them very quickly so there's
an introduction chapter one setting the
scene talking about what the book is
about and how she's gonna proceed and
then she dives right in in Chapter two
with Luca happens Duke of course is a
Buddhist term that's often translated as
suffering and so she's looking at the
Buddhist framework in for understanding
and to some degree dealing with
suffering what was the origin of it then
chapter three she moves over to the
Stoics maladies of the soul why we
suffer and there's a kind of alternating
that's going to go on for a bit chapter
four how to be saved number one Nirvana
so that's the Buddhist response chapter
five how to be saved number two living
in accordance of nature stoic response
right and then she brings those two key
themes together with the remaining
chapters so chapter six is more than
happiness the title of the book right so
that's a really central chapter for the
entire work chapter seven removing the
dust from our eyes looking at how we
wind up in a lot of different mistaken
errors chapter eight is called the sage
and the Buddha models for living it's
actually a little bit miss named I would
say because there's a lot of other stuff
packed in there that you can say the
stage the stomach's a Jay on the Buddha
and Bodhisattvas and whatever other
beings you want to talk about are in
fact practicing these but it's mostly
about their their ideas then there's a
discussion in Chapter nine of spiritual
practice beyond theory the need to
actually do this stuff not just
about it as the Stoics and the buddhists
have reminded us finally chapter 10
contains a really nicely thought out set
of meditations also practices for a
better life and you know this is um in
terms of style it's very readable mcaro
has a great way of discussing these
things in very down-to-earth terms but
without losing I would say as somebody
who has studied this stuff without
losing rigor in the process so I think
it's really quite good the way she's
doing it it's it's very well organized
very well thought through clearly the
the you know outcome of a lot of
thinking and applying these these things
and the one other thing I'll say in
terms of summary is that she's committed
to this view that Buddhism and stoicism
need to be rethought or as she says at
one point resized you notice the the
subtitle for a sceptical age so that's
gonna play a central part in it so I can
do some idea about what you're getting
into if you choose to read this book
this is something that I would say if
you had like a full afternoon and you
wanted to sit down and read your way
through it and you already were familiar
with some of it you could probably read
the entire work in an afternoon
or you could space it out over time as
well
I'm not going to try to summarize the
entire work in depth for you I'll just
talk about a few really key and central
points that I would say run through the
entire work and one of these is that
both Buddhism and stoicism really offer
a lot to their practitioners they are
both robust you can call them
philosophical in the case of Buddhism
you can also talk about it as being a
religious system there's a bit of debate
about that she summarizes some of that
in here quite well in any case they're
robust systems for understanding the
problems and solutions in life they also
are quite demanding of their
practitioners if you want to get the
full package if you want to derive all
the benefits that are that are being
preferred by these these orientations or
these perspectives right so she
recognizes that and she says you know
maybe we don't want to be committed to
everything that's that's there in
Buddhism or everything that they're in
stoicism so it's clearly it what we you
know in terms of stoicism I would call a
modern stoic book right and she's
offering a a way of looking at these
things that she doesn't say it you know
is not a single way to do it but is
quite persuasive her point of view as
she summarizes it is going to be
naturalistic meaning that we don't want
to bring in all sorts of supernatural
entities and and she notes that when it
comes to say you know the Stoics versus
the Buddhists in some some respect the
Stoics have a bit of an edge on Buddhism
as it's actually historically practiced
by people there's less supernatural
elements about it and she stresses that
the the Buddha himself was not
particularly given to talking about
metaphysics except you know later text
that that where the Buddha is
essentially being used perhaps as a kind
of mouthpiece and so this is a very
modern point
view she wants to have a sort of
skeptical attitude about things and now
there's different kinds of skepticism so
this is worth actually dwelling on a bet
for example in the beginning of the work
she you know she talks about well here's
a great line right here before we get
into the setting the scene says my main
aim is to explore what we can extricate
that fits in with a naturalistic
questioning point of view but that is
more than just tips on how to be happy
I've chosen to concentrate on both
traditions the parts of them that have
the potential to make an impact
challenging rather than indulging
receive notions etc etc right and she
goes on and the setting the scene she
tells us listen when it comes to
Buddhism we don't actually know that
much historically about this at this guy
siddhartha gautama who had an
Enlightenment the texts that were
getting are written down much later
based on oral traditions you know in and
she's right within the scholarship of
Buddhism the the serious scholarship
there's there's a lot of like well maybe
this maybe this and the point is well we
don't actually have to be that tied to
those things that you know there's
something I should point out there's a
quest for the historical Jesus there's
also a quest for the historical Buddha a
quest for the historical Confucius this
is what we call the realm of the
historical or historic ality and you
know the skepticism that she has is
mostly aimed at sort of like pushing
away the stuff that isn't going to be
particularly helpful and trying to get
to the core of of what could be useful
for us in the present she's not doing
what some people have done in the past
which is to say well they push this
stuff away and we've got the core of the
historical Buddha right here no she's
not that concerned with that and we can
say a similar thing about stoicism as
well you know we don't have any of the
original text of Zeno the founder of
stoicism or of cruciferous the so-called
second founder the third Skull arc of
the school we have bits and pieces of
what they
said preserved in other people's work
and then we get these accounts coming in
from people like Cicero who's not
himself as stoic but is attracted to
stoicism and sees a lot of value in it
and then we get the late Roman Stoics we
have you know
Epictetus and Seneca Marcus Aurelius we
have bits of Epictetus t'les teacher mr.
O'Neill's Rufus's stuff we have here a
Cleese and then we have another summary
coming from areas didymus and other bits
and pieces so we got to kind of put the
picture together and when we that means
that we don't have to be dogmatically
committed to this particular
interpretation or this particular
interpretation so that's something
running through her her work that plays
a major role I would say another thing
that's going on within her work is she's
doing a great job in showing how
Buddhism and stoicism are both focusing
on some constants of human nature and
not just human nature of us as a kind of
species an animal right but as rational
beings that live in societies there's
certain things that were be devilish
people and causing them to be you know
upset and troubled and you know doing
the same stupid thing over and over
again back in ancient times in India and
everywhere else that Buddhism spread to
and in ancient Greece and Rome where
stoicism caught on and spread to other
places as well so you know that's that's
something worth focusing on as well and
she also brings out the fact that or the
feature rather that that Buddhism and
stoicism although they're not merely
therapies they are therapeutic they are
doing the job of therapy ministering to
the human being in order to allow them
to attain something better for
themselves happiness the happy life or
something more than happiness to use the
title the last point that I'll bring up
by way of summary is that there's a lot
of focus in here on the emotions as
understood both from Buddhist
perspectives
stoic perspectives but also from
psychological perspectives of theories
of the current times and Aristotelian
perspectives as well so there's a lot of
great discussion of emotion and
different viewpoints that you could take
on it within this text
I've already mentioned a few good
features about this work but there's
there's a number of other ones that I do
want to bring up and highlight about
Makka Rose book and the thought that is
so clearly running behind it and within
it and I'll level with you right now I
highly recommend you get this book I
think it's really quite great and I I'm
kicking myself a bit for leaving it on
my shelf for so long before getting to
it so the first good point is really
really well thought through again as
somebody who has been engaging with both
of these main traditions and quite a few
of the other ones that she talks about
in the work particularly the
Aristotelian tradition this is the kind
of book where you're like man I wish I'd
written that book this is you know this
is really well put together and it has
just enough to it to lead you into the
stuff without overwhelming you it was
detail she has a very judicious approach
to things there's there's you know no
partisanship in it she's saying well you
know the Buddhist of this and Stoics of
this let's take this part let's take
this part this is good we're gonna leave
this behind
hey the Aristotelian is over here
they've got some stuff that we want some
other psychotherapeutic techniques of
the present maybe we want to borrow from
them so it's a really great way of
putting this stuff together it's it's
you know it's committed but non-dogmatic
you can say and and I would say that
again this is the fruit of obviously
spending a lot of time not only studying
these these traditions but also
practicing the traditions and engaging
with them it's really well thought
through
she is very realistic about what can be
done and what can't be done using these
these approaches and is quite charitable
I would say quite objective you might
say as well in the sense that she's
getting
the object and trying to remove herself
as much as possible from any sort of
distorting considerations without saying
oh I don't I you know I'm I'm the view
from nowhere she's not doing that sort
of thing
it's very honest in its approach and I
like that as well I wanted to pick out a
particular set of passages this is
coming from about middle-way this isn't
the more than happiness section and she
says that what do these traditions have
to offer a skeptical reader today a
common approach if we wish to avoid
adopting metaphysics that doesn't suit a
scientifically informed worldview is to
cherry-pick bits of advice to act make
us happier or more successful take
mindfulness for example well secular
mindfulness based secular mindfulness
based methods of meditation were
originally developed for therapeutic
purposes it's now being claimed to help
with all sorts of other goals from
making money to spicing up our sex lives
to losing weight and you might expect at
that point for her to be saying well
we're gonna get away from that she says
but there's nothing wrong with
cherry-picking per se in some sense
that's what I'm advocating in this book
the problem is when what's picked only
skims the surface of what is on order
these are demanding traditions that
challenge our customary ways of being in
the world and the values that ordinarily
dominate our life that's an excellent
way of framing it cherry-picking
eclecticism you know she morges Borg
approaches they often are very surface
level this is the problem with lifehack
philosophy right it's it doesn't get
deep enough and it doesn't put enough of
those parts that have been cherry picked
back together and that is really what
she's advocating for doing the opposite
of that cherry picking but but cherry
picking the right stuff and then
arranging them in relation to each other
and consolidating it with practice so
you know I like that sort of approach
and I also like the honesty about it
another thing that's really great about
this work are the exercises and here I
want to like I'm gonna
do a little bit of a ramp so I've looked
at and reviewed a lot of recent books
about stoicism also to some degree I
haven't reviewed them so much but I've
looked at a lot on Buddhism as well and
they tend to like circulate the same
basic sets of practices right everyone
unstow assistive includes negative
visualization there's usually like a
paragraph devoted to it and it's usually
not done particularly well and it sounds
like everybody else's version of it so
when you come across a chapter about
practices or as she's calling them
meditations and there's actually quite a
few it contained in other chapters in
the book and they're really well put
together well thought through well
described that's kind of unusual and so
I'm really happy with not only what
she's picked but how she has expressed
it again real expert writing here the
other thing that I do want to say that I
find compelling about this work is she's
doing really excellent comparative
philosophy in here and doing so without
going into you know super great depth
again there's just enough given to the
reader to sort of promote their own
thinking about this and to get them
steered in the right direction so those
are some of the the really high points
of this work for me
now wouldn't be a Sadler's honest review
if I didn't have a few minor criticisms
of the work and they are indeed quite
minor the first one that I have is that
I think for the casual reader there
could be a little bit of confusion in
how she's talking about the Stoics as
aiming at getting rid of all emotion and
there is some discussion in there about
you know can we distinguish passions
from emotions and and so she is doing
her due diligence in that way I still
think that some of the things that she's
saying could lead people to think that
the Stoics are only recognizing emotions
as problematic or bad and trying to get
rid of them when the Stoics very you
know if she does discuss in here did
distinguish what we call the the good
emotional states that you pave right
rational fear rational desire rational
joy and you know again this is a very
minor complaint because she is handling
it I do think that a casual reader could
still get mixed up about it but now that
I think about it maybe that's the casual
readers vote fault for for not paying
close enough attention to what's being
said another thing that I don't really
buy that she says and this is in the
chapter on living in accordance with
nature is is that the stoic theory of
indifference is connected with their
view that the universe is providentially
ordered and arranged in the most
rational way so we should willingly go
along with whatever unfolds for us in
the world and I don't think that the
doctrine of the indifference namely that
there's a range of things that most
people call goods which are neither good
nor bad they're only preferred or or
dispar furred or rejected this is a
stoic idea and there's much more to say
about this but I'm not going to go into
detail here none of these are actually
good or evil in any real sense I don't
think that that
is in fact connected with the doctrine
of Providence I mean I think you can you
can connect it up together and say well
if you buy both of these at the same
time then this follows which seems to be
what she's saying but I don't think that
there's any intrinsic connection between
the two I think you could buy into one
namely the doctrine of the indifference
without buying into the other the
doctrine of Providence which is what
many modern Stoics in fact do the other
thing that I'll say is that I think I
would have liked have seen discussion of
another way of framing more than
happiness so you know the Stoics talk
about eudaimonia and there's a lot of
discussion in here and that's very good
and in the the chapter devoted to more
than happiness right the sort of
linchpin of the book what else is is
happiness well it's you know equanimity
good flow of life all these sorts of
things which mcaro is quite good about
unpacking and going into detail about
but one thing that I didn't see in here
that I think is important for the Stoics
and you see this in cicero's
presentation of kaitos views in on the
ends book 3 and Senecas letters in
Epictetus to a certain degree and in
other places is this notion that what
really matters is is moral goodness and
that's not distinct from happiness if
you if you are aiming at moral goodness
which is encapsulated in virtue and the
four virtues you are going to be happy
but it's it's a kind of happiness that
goes beyond typical you die monastic
views things and so I think I just want
to like to seen a little bit more
clarification of that in there because
it is part of you know traditional
stoicism this is why some people think
there's a really salt you know strong
deontological side to stoicism and they
they almost view the stoic says like in
some respect conscience before can't
is a controversial topic but I thought
it's good to bring up anyway so I don't
have a lot of deep you know serious
complaints or criticisms of the work
those are my only nitpicks
all right final thoughts and assessments
first off let me just say I
unqualifiedly recommend this book it's
it's really good I don't think that it's
just a book for beginners although I
think beginners can really benefit from
it a lot I really enjoyed this book
myself as somebody who I would say is
sort of like expert level in terms of
the theory and cognitive stuff and sort
of intermediate level in terms of
practicing le stoicism not not so much
Buddhism right but I really enjoyed
reading it I think it's very insightful
I think that practitioners of either
side could actually get a lot out of
having mcaro as as an interlocutor
somebody to say well what about this why
don't you think about this and so I
think it's it's really a wonderful book
and I recommend it there's things you
just heard me say there's not much bad I
can say about it and actually even the
stuff that I said isn't really bad it's
just sort of like little asides so yeah
I'm really a fan of this work and I
would recommend it
you